كل منا يخرج من الجهاز فرحا
أعتقد لك للجميع
نعم لأننا لم نتوقع صعوبة كبيرة
ذكر يؤدي
[موسيقى]
الرغبات العملية بقدم واحدة موجودة بالفعل
كان وراء ياقة القاعة في قوة الإرادة هذه
[موسيقى]
فقط القفز الحديث عن مثل هذا الحدث
عندما استيقظت مجموعة للحصول على رجل
كيف تشعر الان
تمت إزالة الاشتراك المحترف
أصبح papus one لي ، لم يخلعه وسأأكل
منجز
[موسيقى]
انظر إلى قسم القبول
حتى الصالحين لما يستحق واحد قريبا 2
من خلال خذها بدوره
انها قائمة الانتظار
أبعد
في المساء ومجهود اللواء المزيد من الناس
كم تنفق على
شخص واحد لكل موعد
تفعل كل شيء بسرعة الترشيح 40-40
على الرغم من أن القانون
لكن كل من يرتدي البذلة يفعل ذلك
هذا هو السبب في أن الدور هو نفس الشيء
موسكو للقيام بالجهاز الهضمي في العيادات وبالفعل
يتم التشخيص من خلال خلاصة شبكة Prisma
قد نود قضاء 10 دقائق هنا
كثيرا ما تجلب اللغة
[موسيقى]
على ال
بطل الدماغ
[موسيقى]
لشراء التذاكر
فوما اثنين فقط.
[موسيقى]
من سيتصل بشكل جيد
[يضحك]
حتى لا يتم تمزيق الحمولة لهذه كبيرة
جهاز التنفس الصناعي و
جودة
وهؤلاء هم من تفير وبالتالي
كنت
مؤمن عليه
دعونا
[موسيقى]
أنهم أطباء جيدون وكم أصيبوا بالمرض
بالنسبة له ، إلى جانب تقدره الأقواس والأخوات
1212 وكم عدد الموظفين الذين يحبون 2002 1000
جديد من صغير
للسود ، كم عدد الذين يموتون بشكل عام ، و
لا أحد لطيف القانونية مقيد
الاغتسال الله الموظفين حصلت بجد
مريضني أعلن إطارات قوية
تسبب حمامات الشمس في إرباك المرأة بشكل مفرط
إذا كان الناس معنا في مكان ما وللحصول على إضافات
نحن متأخرون واسبوعان من موسكو حتى
عملت موسكو من أجلي موسى يطبخ في المنزل
وكرة من القيء
على سيارة الإسعاف أعطيت خطأ في الوقت
قتل الرجل الجميع مسموما الآن
بدأت بالفعل في العودة للمرض
سيارات الإسعاف النحاسية تعمل الآن في صحتك
يتم إنشاء ظروف العمل العادية
لا يمكنهم استدعاء وطني على الإطلاق
مرض الأطباء
لقد تراكمت لدينا بهجة مثلي
سأخبرك على ما يبدو
[موسيقى]
بشق الأنفس
أيضا لا يصل إلى عاملنا
الخروج بالفعل
أكثر من أنها قاعدة طويلة جدا
الأخوات يصلي أيضا
لكنها في طريقها
أرسين يمكن التحدث عنه
بالطبع ليس هنا وضع الفلين كما
إنه من مليمتر مستشفى قريب حتى
تغذية
رمي لا يقول لا الفم
الأربطة المتوترة المفتوحة.
هم أيضا أكثر من 90 هزيمة كيف حالك
طبيعي ولكنه إيجابي أيضًا
دينا
الغيلان / قريبا معهم الدين الإيجابي
كم العمل عليها
اقتربوا من أسبوع هنا و
زيارة الزحف جمعت الألغام وأنت
يمكنك بالفعل أن تقول نعم وأحسنت
بمجرد إخراجها
كم عمر 45 45 1
[موسيقى]
ولكن كيف وصلت الاستوديوهات إلى هنا منذ ذلك الحين
درجة الحرارة العادية عند ذهني
لماذا كل هذين النوعين
أبريل درجة حرارة الحياة أقصر
النفوس والنفوس
قوارير
جودة هادئة ضربها وقت الجثة
أدرك
وعلى الفور 13 يومًا عند التكسير بقوة و
عازفون منفردون من الرتب الممتازة اللانهائية
المحرك الرئيسي الشاب
طلقات الشباب ثم بشكل غير متوقع لم يكن يتوقع
التقاط الزخم
هنا مع إبر الحياكة
نعم انا على الاطلاق.
دعونا الكرات تساوي 2 كرتين من طالب ممتاز
لكنهم خسروا فكروا وراءها مباشرة
المنطقة وأنت تعرف نعم ولكن وبواسطة
قيل للتلفزيون
قال كل هذا بسبب الطيران الجريء
ويرجى أن يكون لديك شاب يبلغ من العمر 45 عامًا
اسبوعين هيكل انتون هنا ايضا
أوبتارا قامت بعملها على الفور
أخذنا على الفور
[موسيقى]
ثم سيري زوما البصق
لا مزيد من توقعنا عازمة
هذا هو ، في مستشفى اتحادي في موسكو
رقم
أكتوبر لديك حكام لنا
تشارك شخصيا وتزويد هذا المقر لهم
يساعد في المراجعة هناك و
ساعده الموسم النشط في ذلك
الأدوية التي لا تشتعل بالنار أثناء النهار
ستجدنا نتعامل مع من يوجد لي
الزملاء هم أيضا مع المستشفى هناك
سقط رأس الإنعاش مريضا
تم إرسال خاصتي
حسنًا ، بينما هناك ، ونحن ، كيف نعطي؟
تخيلنا في عاصفة أو مقدمًا
بدأت فطائر النورس الآن بالفعل
للقبض عليه مسبقًا ، أي كما فهمنا
أنه يعمل بشكل جيد عندك
تصل إلى النقطة
عندما يتوقف حقًا
أمامك إذا كنت قد اشتقت إليه بالفعل
بالفعل مع القوة والرئيسية ، بالطبع ، ليس هناك بالفعل أي تأثير
نفس ما يقولون ضرب مثل
الآن ، إذا قمت بذلك في الوقت المناسب
على الفور هذا الدواء عندما نرى
كيف يعمل في الواقع
يؤثر على التسبب في التنمية
الأمراض
[موسيقى]
أنا فقط أشتري
كيف حدث 60 ولماذا هو
دخلت في وقت متأخر
ودرجة الحرارة 40 جانبًا ، أي العضو
تركت وحدها هذه العاصفة الكلاسيكية
إذا كنت نشيطا قليلا
في وقت سابق ربما يمكنك ذلك في اليوم
أن ينتهي بك الأمر ليس في العناية المركزة في المعتاد
جناح
لكني كنت سأدخل بعد يوم
لن تذهب إلى أي مكان من خلال اشتراكية أخرى
لم يعط أي أمراض على الإطلاق
كان لإعطاء المزمن هنا للرياضي ولكن أنا
لم أحضر وثقت بي
الرفاهية ، ولكن ، كما كانت ، لرياضاتهم
النتائج وأيها ليست كذلك ، حسنًا
الكارتون عبر الإنترنت سيظل الكثير
مطاردة الرياضة 10 سنوات
أداء ألعاب القوى بشكل جيد لا لزوم له
الثقافة ، حسنًا ، من الصعب علينا الغناء
ستكون على هذا النحو ولكن - حسنًا ، تم سحب الجميع
على عدد مرات الضغط على مقاعد البدلاء
الكمية وأنت تحبني على وجه الخصوص
لم أذهب إلى المستشفى في الليل
ساحة كيف حدث ذلك لك
غاب 43 كم يوما يشعر
بقيت لفترة طويلة
في الشارع يعمل في أرضه
المؤامرات شنق مثل هذا أبي جيد
أشعر أنني لم أبرر أنهم طلبوا البراعة
سأمرض في الموقع ، حسنًا ، كان هناك مثل هذا
الوضع على ما يرام ، وكما كان ، ما يصل إلى مائة حرب
ثم بدأت ببطء في التطور
درجات الحرارة الموعودة حيث أصبحت معتدلة 1
حسنًا ، لقد اتصلت بالفعل يوم الاثنين بالطبيب
جاء واحد فقط
وصف مضادات الفيروسات كيفية السماح لها بالذهاب
المدارات جيدة هناك للرضا عند الملوك
بالطبع ، هذا هو أفضل دواء للجميع.
لم اشرب الامراض يوم الاربعاء
دعا في السوق وضع اتجاهين
تم وصف الالتهاب الرئوي بأنه مضاد حيوي
الحد الأقصى من الأموال التي تمر بها في المنزل
كتب amoxiclav هناك
لا يزال لدي سؤال للروح على المعالج
ربما كشخص في المنزل للعلاج
رأس أكريليك قليلاً شيء مثل هذا
يميز البراز تمامًا ويضع كل شيء
حسنًا ، شعرت أن كل شيء كان بالفعل بالنسبة لي
لا يمكنك الخروج بنفسك وبالفعل
دعا من هنا للمساعدة في الرياح العابرة
هنا فجور الجبابرة بسرعة حول ما سبق
أكثر من 200 دقيقة فائدة الطريق في المقدمة
بالطبع لديك بالفعل البقايا
يمكن أن يموت في أي عمر إذا
لم يصنع الشموع بشكل صحيح
لا يوجد أي شخص محمي على الإطلاق
100٪ لا يصدق تماما
الآن حالة الضغط على الحارقة 97
جرب 98 كسر إدمان
حظا سعيدا لا يصدق لك
[موسيقى]
كم كتبت
يمكنني بالفعل تعليق الخرز ، لكن كل هذا كان من أجله
فلاش اختيار الضيوف التعدين
لأكون صادقًا ، لا أعرف عن الآخرين
المستشفيات اعرف وزني 700
رجل تلقيته بالفعل
حاليا في المستشفى
الزاوية 500
العمل ليس اشهر فقط بل هو ضروري و
500 هو kommunarka يصل إلى 500 شخص لي
في مكان ما حوالي 450 رسميًا لكنها تقع دائمًا
500 أكثر
مرة أخرى تبدأ بشكل جيد رسميًا سأفعل ذلك
لمجرد أن أبحر
نحن نؤخذ بشكل خاص إلى الأنف نعم
نعم الكواكب هنا في الصباح تحتك
اكتب اترك هذا المكان 20 يحدث هناك
و 30 مكانًا تشاهدها في صباح اليوم التالي
بالفعل هم مشغولون بالفعل في الممرات الآن
مثل هذا بعد مايو تدفق وحدة
لكم حتى بدأ الاحترام الركود الاسباني
كيف لم نلاحظ الركود أو هناك بالطبع
أبقى منتشرة كل إضافية
أسرة
هذا هو ، لديك حقًا بعد مايو
بدأت العطلات تنمو الآن 12
يبدو أن الأيام أصغر ، وهكذا كان النمو
كبير وماذا ش عندما في اليوم
تصرف 50 شخصًا لكي تنفخ
المقدسة كم عادة عادة خلال
كوريتا بوذا كم
ذهبت إلى العيادة في ذلك اليوم ، لكن لدينا عيادة
باشارين آلاف الأسرة في مكان ما لدينا دائمًا
كانت على متن رحلة من 200 شخص
معدل
في بعض الأحيان أصغر ولكن مع الطوارئ 200
سوف نفهم و كل النوبات القلبية هنا
سيصبح المركز عمل يقول كيف الطريقة أنا
انها ربع الآن
لقد ضغطنا الآن قليلاً على المخطط
المساعدة وتحت تسليم مستشفيات المدينة
ولأنه حاول أكثر
فيلق لنزع فتيل المرضى قليلاً ، سنفعل
الولادة ليعيش ثم عندما لا
إنشاء نقاط ساخنة لـ
[موسيقى]
قيد التجربة
مرهق تمامًا وهو ما لا يُعطى لنا الناس و
سيتعين على البلاد الرئة وحتى الآن أو غير ذلك
انظر الحب يقرأ
على الأرض وغادر الرجل العجوز تمامًا
من الصعب بيع مثل هذه أو
إنهم ليسوا 98 فقط ينظرون إلى نفسي 0
لا شيء على الإطلاق ، لا يهم على الإطلاق
هنا هذا القسم في
مصطنع ، هذا هو عليه الآن
لأعمالك رميت كل البوابات
كل هذه الفنون لم يكن هناك شيء هنا
أنت تعطيها إلى غرفة سائق غرفة سيدة المجلد
سوف ترفع Comme المشنقة يمكنك تقديم و
على الأزرق
[موسيقى]
كانت درجة الحرارة لدي 39 لمدة عشرة أيام
حلها هل يمكن أن تقترح لي
لقد تعلمت المضادات الحيوية بنفسي أسطورة
تم تعيين طبيب
أوبرادوفيتش لا أتذكر أي شيء
استيقظت لمجرد.
اتصلت بسيارة إسعاف وسمعت صوت الاتصال الداخلي في بدلتي
استقبال امرأة لا يمكن أن تتذكر
اسمه الأخير أو يطلب أسماء العائلة و
الآباء ينظرون إليهم يبتسمون في ما إذا كان
هل لا يزال مع الجواز بناء على ما إذا كانت الشركة
فينجا بحاجة للاحتفال به جولة ضخمة جدا
حسنًا ، أخبرنا فومين بتغيير النقاط
خرجت من كوفاليف لتذكر أن تدحرجت
قادته وأخرجه فأرقد في الموت
لأنني أتذكر شظايا فقط
أحداث هجوم المحادثات
عندما استيقظت سألتك كيف تريد
لذلك يبدو أن لدينا أغنيتين أفضل
رقم
إنها تصل إلى 7 وهو موجود بالفعل بشكل عام نحن الصورة
أنه دخل 20 بالفعل 7
عادة من شعورك بالرضا
كانت المضاعفات الوقت الذي هو جيد مثل هذا
ليس محركًا لإرسال تفريغ البهجة
ميزان التنظير مثل الفيديو هنا المجد
فعل الله كل شيء
كم من الوقت بعد
والافراج عن دولة 10 لنا الخروج
يجب أن يكون الإنعاش قد سار على ركبتيه
تهتز منطقة تتشبث بالعارضة و
ستأتي إلى هنا أو ستكتشف ذلك
شهية كما بدت ، لا يزال بإمكانك القيادة
لذلك لدينا شهية جيدة إيجابية
أردنا مقابلتي في المنزل
ألا ترى الكثير من العائلة
المنزل عادة أقل نعم هذا هو كيف
سوف تذهب بالفعل لا أحب هذا هو أنت
لا هنا فترة الضمان بعد هذه
نعم لا نعم نعم نحسب تحليلين
لا تترك السلبية لك الآن
2 تحليلات يتم إجراؤها من قبل المريض أو
أعلن
ثم على الفور تجعلك لا ليس لديك أمس
قريبا مثل التدخين بسبب
ماذا او ما
في هذا الصدد ، كيف الأسرة طبيعية
هيا ، لكنني لم أذهب إليهم ، أنا أبحث عنهم
موقع عمل البوم نفس مصير المساعدة
لكن مع تقدمي في العمر ، فأنا لست جالسًا بالفعل في المرتبة العاشرة
اشهر ممتعة مثل اطفالنا من خلال
مقاعد البدلاء نعم اقول لكم حدسي بحت
لن نذهب فقط مع
أكل وإخوانه هذه القصة مرة أخرى
ABC يتحدث الجميع عنها وتحت العيون
لا أحد رأى ولكن من المحتمل أن يكون مرة أخرى
وأي مضاعفات أي نزع كل شيء
لا يزال يعطي ندوب على الجليد تحت مثل
[موسيقى]
مثل حلقات المفاتيح
كان نقطة ضعف
ضيق في التنفس مثلي تجويد بوريس أنا
يسمى الجرب بالفعل مرتين والأنظمة التي
لأنني لا أعرف أن فيروس كورونا موجود هنا و
أنا نفسي أشارك في النظام طوال الشهر ومعه
هذا هو السبب في عدم وجود شيء من هذا القبيل الآن
لاحقًا ، عندما أدركت أنني لم أفعل ذلك
أنا أقف على قدمي
أن لدي ضعف وأضع نفسه
اللحم قبل ذلك لم يستسلم إذا كان اثنان
اختبار العمل المذاب حصلوا علي
سلبية بطريقة ما كنت
متأكد تمامًا من تلك المهارة والراية
المريض يتنفس بالطبع كان الضابط
تظهر طوال العام أعطى سلبية
هذه اللحظة
إذاً لقد وصلت إلى هنا ، لقد وصلت أولاً
بدأت في التبول الشرطي إلى مستشفى المدينة بعد ذلك
حل المشكلة لأنني بحاجة
تهوية تحويل اسم المجال بالفعل
الرئتين وحسنًا ، نعم ، ما دمت واضحًا
طالما أنك تعرف ما تحتاجه
كان في أي تمرين 87 في المئة
على الآخرين
إنه مجال أقل بوقاحة
نعم ، أعتقد أنني أستطيع ، الحقيقة هي إذا
لم يتم إطلاقه تجولت أنه من الواضح أنه لم يأخذها
ستولي اهتماما
بطريقة مختلفة حبيبتي لديك على الفور
وضع
لا أستطيع أن أقول على وجه اليقين ، أود ذلك
حتى عند توضيح كل نفس الشيء
تشبع ما كان السباحة
تخيل رجلا
في ذلك الوقت لم يكن لدي أي اتصال
أقارب وأن خارج النافذة على قيد الحياة للحظة
ما إذا كان هذا العالم قد يمضغ من قبل أقاربي
الطول هنا كان أفظع ما يصل إلى 20
مارست اليوجا كنت أتأمل
أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك هنا يمكنني أن أفعل ذلك
عرض تعال تعال وداعا نعم بالطبع هنا
ربما أكذب هنا ، لدي القليل من كل شيء هناك
وزن أنبوب الجوز والدك ليس كذلك
تظهر الطرق هناك كل شيء أظهر نفسه
في أجهزة الاستشعار هنا لدي لك هذا أنا
بحاجة إلى أن تصبح كل متر هنا أنا
15 دقيقة تحاول التأليف وبعد ذلك
أنت تعرف ماذا ترفع بدون جهاز
يجب أن أستسلم ، وهذا هو ، لا بد لي من البركة
الغراء للأنبوب ، أود أن أحب هذا
ينتقل هنا إليه يجلس
استرخ ثم انتهينا من ذلك
للتعافي قليلا ونفس الشيء
15-20 دقيقة أجلس وأتنفس الطعام
بحيث ينهار بعد ذلك
تحاول النهوض وضعف الساقين
خذ القليل من البخار
تدوس قليلاً كل شيء حافي القدمين
شكرا مرة أخرى نظارات marinochka منظم
لقد عذبنا أمامي وقدم هدية
أعطت رداء حمام يمكنني رميها عليه
لا تقف عارياً في حفاضات ثم معها
استمر مقص يسأل أي نوع من العلاج
ساعدت التربية البدنية حتى نعم سيفعلون
من فضلك النباح
يمكنني التأمل بهدوء
لا يمكن اكتشاف المادة المظلمة هنا
هذا هو ، كان علي أن أفعل
الأسلاك حتى لا تتداخل معي الأسلاك
يتدحرج ثم استيقظ كل شيء و
المدرسة يمكن للمرء هنا زميل المرئية
وهذا كل شيء وأنت
كل الأرقام لم تكن موجودة وكان كل شيء لا يزال و
مقالات هرمية
والآن أجلس بهدوء عند اكتمال القمر
صليت لنيكولاس ولكن أنت لماذا أعيش
العامل المعجزة 5 ساعات الذي أعطاها
الهدية الأولى كانت رداء 2
سكايب حيث اكتشفت أنه كان على قيد الحياة لي
الأطفال على قيد الحياة أردت بسرعة
احصل على السيطرة
نعم ، لأن الدنمارك على ما يبدو
لم يعرفوا طوال العام قليلاً
ماذا كان هناك
كنت قلقة على الطبيب الذي يراني
جاء هذا اللواء الذي جاء
حسنًا ، لم أكن أعرف ملحدًا ، لم يأخذوه بعد
عرفت نتيجة لهم ثم سآخذ
لكن الاسم ، بالطبع ، لقد اختبرت كل شيء ، كنت أعرف
الذي ينجو من كفاحي عائلتي و
الضغط بشدة
لقد كان مؤلمًا جدًا بالنسبة لي لأنه
أنني أجلب الألم أنهم يفقدون صحتهم
لأن tyuron أظهر لي معها
بدا الأمر وراشيد هكذا رأيت الآن
ثم تغرد سعيد وأدرك العنوان
التقدم في السن خلال هذا الوقت بينما أنا
يتعافى
وهذا هو السبب في أنني لم أجند ، ولهذا لم أفعل
على أن
الملاح الآلي الآن أنا بحاجة إلى المزيد
أكثر لأن لدي زوج بعد ذلك
يجب عليك وبعد ذلك بالضبط نفس الشيء
يرتفع الباب ووعده هنا
أي نوع من الرجل يتحدث سكايب يقول
لا أستطيع ولكن سآخذ بعيدا مع الإيماءات أصبحت لهم
جدا علاقات المحبة وأنت كثير
جلدة معا فقط بما فيه الكفاية
انظر إلى تعبيرات الوجه
يصعب التواصل لا يمكن أن يصدر صوتًا
وأنا الوحيد على هذا النحو أنا
الحب و
نعجن رئتيها الآن لديها وقت طويل
سيتم استعادة smartart ستظل كذلك
لمدة شهرين تقريبًا ، علينا جميعًا أن نحل
لم يعد موجهًا جدًا على الخريطة عندما
التفريغ لأنهم متأخرون جدا
خلف العيادة إذا كانت موجهة على الخريطة
لا يزال الأمر يستغرق بضعة أشهر
هنا الجناح وحتى تحتاج فقط
اجعل الخلود سيرجي هنا أنت جيد فيه
ربما يكون المركز زوجين بينما أنت
هزيمة 7 في المئة نعم هناك حتى
المزيد كان على وشك اللعب 5 الآن بالفعل 1
البخار وسنكون العيادات الخارجية لها بشكل عام
لديها فيروس من حيث المبدأ بالفعل
لا يوجد جسد ، لقد غادر بالفعل ، ولكن هذا
إنها وراثية ، كل هذه الآليات ليست كذلك
أطلقت الآن يجب أن ماكر
تذوب
وبالطبع نود هذا
كانت التغيرات الليفية أقل عائقًا
لأن الأعداء هنا هم ماء ، حسنًا ، لا
مليئة بأي مكان تذهب إليه
سيكون هناك بعض الالتهابات
التغيرات الليفية في الرئتين وأكثر
طريق طويل إلى الشفاء لأن
له مبدأ الآن في الغالب قمم
فقط يتنفس جيدا ، ما هو هذا الشغف تانيا
الحياة ، أعتقد أنها سوف تتعامل مع هذا
مهمة مع إعادة التأهيل لكنك بشكل عام
نموذج البقاء على قيد الحياة على الأكثر حرفيًا
سيكون من الجميل أن نقول ملابس الكفاءة
أن كل شيء لا يزال في الوقت الحالي
تعال إلى حواسك إذا كنت على الأقل
أمضى شهر ونصف
لن نذهب إلى أي مكان أحب داريا
حتى هناك تعليمات مفيدة لدينا
المرضى حتى يمتثلوا لجميع التدابير
الأمان
لهذا السبب
اريد ان يفكر الناس
لأن باريتو 28 لا أحد يجيب أ
شبابنا الاصدقاء المقربين ولكن هذا
بشكل عام 20 80 لديك و 20 أتمنى بالضبط
فقط لا ترفع دعنا نقول ذلك
كل شيء صحيح يرتفع ذلك
80 في المائة من الشاي يباع
ما إذا كان الجهاز مفقودًا بشكل مصطنع
ينجو ويموت على سائقك على الإطلاق
انها ليست في روسيا بالنسبة لي
لا يختلف عن نيويورك شكرا لك
اصبعك فريقنا جدا
شكرا
[موسيقى]
هيذر الفم شيسو له
كان Radori مشكلة كبيرة في ذلك
حاكم 50000 أحضر لنفسه ما
مرت دا على التوالي ليأتي والمأوى
حسنًا ، بالطبع ، وافقت على أنني أبحث عن نعم
في مكان ما أسابيع حوالي أسبوع وصلنا
هناك اعتبروا كل واحد منهم في وقت لاحق
هذا الحجم القلقاس طبيعي
الشافطة بخير لها نظارات أيضًا
أول محل للسرقة من قبل هذا المحور ل
النجارة اللائقة تحت الماء
الآن في مكان ما مع النظارات فهي أسهل
الأمن القابل لإعادة الاستخدام هي الآن
قبل كل شيء ونفس الشيء ليس هو نفسه
أنت تقول مورد لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه
إن محيط موسكو فعال بشكل خاص هناك
بعد كل شيء ، هناك ما هو أكثر من العاصمة
الفرص الطبية
يعمل بالنسبة لي الناس مختلفون
تخصص هناك طبيب وأخصائي أمراض الرئة
أخصائي الأمراض المعدية يعمل لدي وطبيب عيون و
أطباء أمراض النساء على التوالي بشكل جيد
بطبيعة الحال لدينا بالإضافة إلى المنطق
القسم لديه المتخصصين الذين
قيادة
إنهم على دراية وخبرة كبيرة
أمراض الدم الجيدة لنا من الأعمال
بطريقة ما يتم أخذ السيطرة بجدية و
بدأ الشجب يتم إزالته من الجهاز
في البداية ، بالطبع ، كان مثل هذا الصداع.
كم هو الشخص العادي الذي لديه
الذي تمت إزالته كشف وضع
أيام من جسم الطائرة وأكثر حتى واحد
مقذوف أكثر وأكثر
للأسف هنا واجب سيء المرضى
أنت الغازية بالفعل لاحظنا ذلك
ارقام اخافتنا الصين 90
في المئة في أمريكا 80 في المئة
عقلية الفاني عند غزوها
لكنها قريبة من الحقيقة التي تم فحصها ونشرها
protsenko هو أيضا يد
70 في المائة ، كل هذا متشابه ، على الأرجح
نحتاج إلى مثل هذه الأرقام ونخرج كل شيء هنا
للأسف نحن نفس الشيء هنا
لا يوجد سحرة ، كل قوانين الطبيعة ليست هي نفسها
كل نفس ، نحاول على الفور لا
النبات ، ولكن فقط كما هي
من ناحية أخرى هذا مستحيل
أو ما إذا كنت هنا إذا كان يمكنك ذلك
سحب إلى نتيجة المرحلة الأخيرة بالفعل
تم نقلها ، أي أنها قد تم تسريحها بالفعل
مرر نائب مجلس الدوما منا لا من
أراضينا ، لم ترغب في الذهاب
كوموناركا
قلت لكننا نلعب بشكل جيد ومشهور
أحسنت ، كيف هي الإجازة ، لذا نعم ، وهي
يجب أن تؤخذ إلينا أيضًا في الخارج
خذ موسيقى الراب التي لا تعرفها ، نعم كل شيء يدور حوله
لا ينبغي أن يكون جبل كل الرئتين الصالحين ولكن
كان مجرد مقص ضخم للطابعة
اثنين من الخياشيم الايجابيات خاص ابيض ابيض كل
تلك هي العواقب
اثنان لا نعم انهم هنا مفاجأة تخمين ماذا
هنا يعرف كيف يتعامل مع المكعبات
تحدث معه عن طبيعة الفراغات
تسليم برطالمايا
كيف حالك كامرأة
نائب في مجلس الدوما كان لدينا
الإقليمية لا سحب هنا عملت معها
عملت في الصباح
في المساء عدت إلى المنزل لدرجة الحرارة
زيادة ، اعتقدت أن الأمر سيستغرق الكثير
فجر فقط حيث درجة الحرارة لا تسمح بذلك
حصلت علي 39 6
يعتبر أن الوقت قد حان للتفكير وهذا كل ما لدينا
لذلك قضيت أسبوعًا عندما كنا هنا على الفور
خذني لأنك لست في سيارات أجنبية و
أنا ممتن جدا لأنني
آخرها كان موقفًا قديمًا منخفضًا
أعلن كم من الوقت رقد لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع
فشل كل يوم أعطى ما
حبوب الدواء التي ساعدت العقل
الإعلان عن الاستنساخ
ماديا التصحيح جاء لي وقال
كلمات مثل هذا الدواء كما يقول
أو هنا وهناك
على حق وأنت هي هكذا أنت لي
أتحدث فقط عن نفسي هناك وليس
فمن الضروري هنا وبالتالي هذا المرض
الذين ليسوا أطباء ولا يعرفون ما هو
المرض والمرضى نحن ولكننا نخاف فيه
التي لا نعرفها حقًا
استيقظ غدا فلن تستيقظ الناس
خائف فقط وإليك نظرة جديدة على
نحن الآن كل شيء كل شيء كل شيء جيد كل شيء
رائع جدا أولا نظيفة جدا
النقاط التي تعرفها كيف هو اليوم ومتى
هذا منطقي يؤثر بشكل رهيب على الفور
قالوا عندما جاءوا
39 و 6 لم يقلا ما إصلاحا جيدا
ضوء وممرضة أحضره تغيرت
سيكون
لا يزال يمسح ، لا أعتقد أن تؤتي ثمارها
لا شيء مثل النظر إلى والتالي
خيمة الأسد تمسح بالفعل يحدث لك
حتى بالفعل هذه اللحظة كانت
برحمة قررت مسحك في كل مكان
كل شيء ولكن لا شيء للتكيف مع ذلك
اتضح أن نعم نعم نعم أنا كل شيء عن الشاي
ما بفضلك وصحتك ولك
شكرا لكم جميعا شكرا جزيلا أريد
أخبر جميع الأطباء للجميع وكل شيء
الموظفين و
من هم darochka في و غال نحن هذا
أي الطلاب جاءوا هنا ليقولوا
يقولون الفتيات خائفات
كما تعلم ، نعم ، إنه مخيف بالطبع ، لكن
كن يعرف كيف كبيرة ضخمة
لكن من الصعب أن تبدأ الحديث في السادسة
على مدار الساعة أدخل منطقة التحرير والسرد
وبشكل عام ، لا يشرب كارني شيئًا
المرحاض ضد حدوث حتى ذلك الحين
إعطاء انحناءة منخفضة لجميع السيارات الطبية
كذبة نفسها كان الجميع بصحة جيدة وأن لا أحد
لم يمت في هذه الحرب الرهيبة في الحرب
انه مرئي
التفاف هنا لاطلاق النار عليه وهنا العدو
غير مرئية وغير مرئية 3 يقفز من ذلك
سفيتا
إنها ساعة ، لكن بصراحة ، لديّ هناك
بكى أطفالي كثيرا
لا يزال يقول
شكرا شكرا
الصحة لا تدين لك هكذا قل
شكرا ، تأكد من أن تقول شكرا للجميع
كان كل الأطباء
سقط أرضا
[موسيقى]
وأنت العيادة الوحيدة في الجبال
مثل
أو ليس الوحيد الذي نأخذه
بمرض خطير هذا هو الشر الذي
استمر كان
هنا يسهل على المرضى أخذ المدينة
مستشفى 6 بسعة 700 سرير وفي نفس المكان
يقدم المساعدة الجراحية ولكن أي
مثل هذا المهر مع هدية
يمكنك أن ترى أين يرتبط بالنزيف معنا
هنا والمزيد
وكم كنت في البداية الآن
منتشرة لـ 30 سريرا ومبتكرة
الآن كانت العيادة تنتشر
مطلوب بالفعل تقريبا لدينا من خلال
هل سيتعين علينا تغيير المركز كثيرًا
الذي يعمل يؤخذ سخيف ولكن
بطبيعة الحال كان هناك تفشي وهم
لقد تبين أنكم جميعًا ثقيلون وليسوا كثيرًا
كثيفة لذلك الإحصاءات غير متوفرة حتى الآن
تخذل بالطبع
من المرجح أن نهلك بشدة
كل ذلك لأن الالتواء مصطنع
الكلى نظمت هذا فقط معنا و
لذيذ. كم لدينا
16 مريض
وندد الودائع وعند الجهاز
الأجهزة ولكن
إنها حوالي 12 ، لكن دعنا نفكر في كيفية ذلك
قررت ولكن لأن مثل هذه الكمية
من هؤلاء المرضى آخذ في الازدياد ولكنه بدأ بالفعل
اكتبها ، لحسن الحظ ليس كل شيء
إنهم خائفون من الموت
[موسيقى]
لذلك لم أقل عن الوقوف على البكاء
انتهى ، لا يزال لدينا قاعة كبيرة
أن بناء
حيث يتلقى مرضى غسيل الكلى لدينا
لدينا فافا كلوي اصطناعي
أجهزة جديدة جيدة كنا هنا منذ ذلك الحين
تولى القضية أفضل الأحدث و
من الصعب إصلاحه هنا ، وهذا هو
هذه الخيام الصغيرة
منع هذا النوع يأتي على ثلاثة
كل مزقت هنا
garona التاريخ الطبي ، أي أنهم هنا
املأ وهناك منطقة نظيفة بالفعل
طبع أثناء العمل مع أخيه
ظاهرة أنك تعمل في مستشفى بمفردك
أنت أو نفسك طالب عاطل عن العمل وعن كل شيء
تكسب من قبل المنافسين 2121 ثم هذا
نفسي بعد كلية الطب
حتى يعمل الطبيب
بعد ذلك بقليل نحب أنفسنا
يعمل كأنني لم أسمح لي بذلك
ليس مخيفا ولكن
لا ، ليس حقًا ، ولكن عندما تنتهي
الى اين انت ذاهب الى المنزل
هناك ثم انها جيدة على الاطلاق لا احد
لا يوجد صنبور أنطون استقر في الفندق
شجار زفاف علينا جميعًا
يعيش الفريق في الفندق يدفع
الميزانية الإقليمية ما تصميم و
سأدفع مقابل الفنادق ، اكتب الحقل نعم
بالطبع تعطي يتم حل هذه المشكلة وهذا كل شيء
الذي لا يريد أن يذهب إلى الأسرة في كثير
هم أنفسهم أرادوا العيش معنا في الفنادق
يوجد فندق بارك بالقرب من المدينة
مباشرة في الحديقة dodon jivasya نركض وهذا كل شيء
قوة ل
نقول لكم رسميا طبق جانبي جيد
أصلح العالم
لدينا نوع من المشاكل هنا ، حسنًا ، أكثر
رموا كل هذه الأنواع من المناديل
دور المجاري sorel
والآن أرسلت ليغو واحدة
نشأت من الأقفال الخاصة بهم وهناك كل شيء
[ __ ] لكن لا يرتدون الزي العسكري
تم تنظيف قسم من كل شيء هناك قليلا الرطب
دعنا نتغلب على ذلك
لكن مثل هذه الأشياء كبيرة ، نعم لا صك بيع
كما ينبغي حتى قناع الغاز دعنا نذهب
إلى الأمام بين الجثث
زميلة ثم خفضت البرك لا
تقدم
ثم تبللت ولكن البطارية لا تزال
إنها الوحدة الثانية الجديدة للبطل المعدية
تكريم ليغو التي أمراض الدم بالفعل
أكثر من 6 ساعات تعبت من الغسالات
حسنًا ، هذا هو الشيء الصحيح للقيام بذلك
لكنك تحتاج إلي هنا بأكبر قدر من النغمة مثلي هنا
إضافة ما يصل في كل وقت إلى ما لا نهاية
الجودة ذهابًا وإيابًا في المستشفى
مثل المرحاض الذي يزوره شخص ما
603 ضع في اعتبارك هذا على الحائط بشكل عام
4 مقابض يمتلكها التنين بعمر 2
وسيغلق شقيق صديقك في العناية المركزة
في الوضع الثقيل المحفوظة ولكن التكبير 40
اقتبس الثانية من قبل الهدف HD
ولكن في نفس الوقت في كل ولاية لم يتم بعد
هرب نيمه السلوفاكي غرام
ماذا تفعل مع ارتفاع الحرارة
طائرة 6
تم تثبيت نظائر خرطوشة النهاية المسروقة
3.3
[موسيقى]
هذا هو ، يرجى تشويه
الآن أفضل بشكل عام والكواكب
البرتقالي وفي الحمام مرحبا
بدأت عقليا كان هذا مؤكسج
التلاوة
كم هو صعب ولكن لا نجلس في وضعنا
لأن حالة الورقة كالضعف
مثل هذه الرسوم البرية بشكل عام كانت تتحرك ولكن
من فضلك كان الكعك مثل هذا الضعف
بنادق غبية
الإحصائيات أو حتى في الصباح
الوعي
وجهها ولكن لم تكن هي نفسها عالية كانت تبلغ من العمر 38 عامًا
يقول أنه لا يمكن أن يكون ، لا يصدق الجميع
[موسيقى]
أن هذا هو التورنت الخاص بي لأن لدي
لن يكون عليك اختبار الاختبارات و
كنا متماسكين مع الطقس عندما كان الأول
إيجابي في نسبة يوم
واجبة وثالثة ايضا
ينفي الذنب ليس لدي ما يلومني
كانت درجة الحرارة قد انتهت يوم 30 ليلا
طار 6 حق ثم فوقه على ما أعتقد
أن مصارعة الثيران أعتقد أن القوس هو نفسه
عندما أظهرت القطط أداءً جيدًا
على هذا الوصف يمكنني أن أنمو
عدوى فيروسية تصيب الرئتين
اوراق اشجار
عندها فقط أدركت وبدأت أسهل من
الآن أصبح القتال أسهل بكثير الآن
نشر الإنعاش في الطابق الأول
شيئا فشيئا تملأ
هنا أيضًا ، يجب أن يكون هناك بالفعل بالطبع 3
أي نوع من داغستان سيكون مطلوبًا هنا
العالم موطن
ثابت هنا يجرؤ على أن نكون صادقين
هناك مثل هذه الرياضة لأنواع الناس
مات أو oxolin هذا أنا ولكن
سأعلم
على الأرجح ، يموت 100 نوع
حقيقة أن جميع الأمراض تتفاقم
رجل مات مني مات مؤخرا
حفر أي مرق للدخول
لم يعد يبحث عنها حدث لها
نوبة قلبية ولكن البخار أيضا لدرجة أننا حتى
كانت هناك فجوة في وضع الدعامات في كييف
يفهم كل شيء وتكتبه على أنه
معلومات
بالطبع ، بالطبع ، وفي نفس الوقت في إيطاليا
سيكون مكتوباً عصيدة ، نعم ، نعم ، سيشيرون
لا يهمني ماذا
المتنافسة ذات الصلة ولكن هنا في
بطريقة ما لهذا السبب في نيويورك
رضيع لكني أكتب هذا النوع من هذا لنا
أيضا كل جلد رئيسي ندرسه
اذهب الحساء الذي أصنعه بشكل مستقيم بشكل عام
إحصائيات الوفيات من كل شعاع
بصراحة ، أنا لا أفهم على الإطلاق
كيف تضيف ما يصل إلى الإحصائيات بشكل جيد
هنا أود أن أتغذى على وحدة التغذية الخاصة بهم تتداخل مع كل شيء
عندما تكون هناك بالفعل ، لا أفعل
أنا أعرف هذا الاهتمام ولذا فنحن جميعًا نقدم أنفسنا
وجميع التشخيصات مكتوبة على الموقع
على خلفية مشروع ديفيد نعم نعم نعم يقولون
من نوبة قلبية ، كم لديك
الوفيات في هذه المجموعة
9 إلى 20 حسنًا ، أعتقد أنه سيكون هناك هوسي
لم تعد تبلغ ذروتها الآن
الذروة سيذهب كل شيء وبعد ذلك بأفضل ما في وسعه
مكان تشارلز يرتفع في موسكو نظرا
فقط في النهاية حصل لي على ما يبدو
ما زلت في طريقها إلى رقم 10
آفة داخل إجازة مرضية
من الصعب جدًا بالنسبة لي الحكم على ما لدينا
التوجيه جدولة لدرجة أنني جعلت
دلاء من أثقل المرضى والرئتين
يفعل الآخرون في المستشفى
فقط حول معابدهم بدوره مرافقة
كل هذه المدينة 3 كل يوم مقابل 70
رجل داشا يقودنا إليك بالطبع
الآن الذروة
و
[موسيقى]
حفظ تريد حقًا شيئًا ضخمًا
شكرا لتقول تأكد من القول
شكرا لكم جميعا وجميع أطبائنا
أفضل السوفييت
[موسيقى]
قطر سيخرج ، رأيت كم لديهم
أنا أعمل لأن هناك واحدة إضافية أمامي
أنا لا أعرف حتى ماذا أسأل
الجري ينقذ حياة شخص ما فقط
مجنون حتى الأزياء يمكن أن تعمل
حيث من الصعب
نعم ، لهذا السبب أريد فقط أن أقول منخفضة
القوس وشكرا لكم على شكرنا
[موسيقى]